[Musique]
père et fils une tournée pas comme les
autres
[Musique]
chez moi
le printemps de bourges commence fort
les opportunistes d'un soin ou allumer
le w en s'amusant
[Musique]
m
mine de rien si je peux me permettre
même si tu es mon papa que voilà je
regardais comme mon père mais on assume
on a un côté copains aussi quand même un
peu enfin moi je suis quand j'ai
commencé à traîner quoi j'avais 20 ans
et qu'il y avait un côté copains quand
même fin donc jouer ensemble c'est joli
quand on fait de la musique on dit pas
on travaille sûrement dit on joue moi je
trouve que je trouve qu'il ya de ça
vraiment dans les concerts on s'amuse
vraiment
[Musique]
se faire plaisir et en donner à un
public de connaisseurs jazz manouche et
grands maîtres
il était devant et
avec des gens un peu plus âgés que nous
autour et les gens nous regardent et
emmenés elles savent qu'elles
connaissent les paroles sa fin on les
connaît oui paris s'éveille
cactus
alors c'est nous pas enfin tout ça je
crois que c'est un peu nos madeleine de
proust
la qualité est musicien enfin moi je les
ai trouvés
errants géniaux quoi le vote est unanime
pas besoin de choisir là ça la beauté du
trou luttons tous les musiciens sont non
seulement très talentueux mais des
crèmes des amours en vain et puis voilà
on partage je crois que des moments de
complicité sur scène très important mais
c'est vrai c'est important
[Musique]
m
on y pensait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]